la liberté surtout c'est ça qui me plaît
le plus dans ce métier car vous avez
l'impression d'être libre
ah oui c'est la liberté la vie du
marinier en 1968 sur les canaux qui
relie l'atlantique à la méditerranée
en ce temps-là le canal du midi le plus
prestigieux voiliers passer des dizaines
de péniches tous les jours un temps
révolu
aujourd'hui ce sont les bateaux de
plaisance qui sans bouteille aux écluses
le tourisme fluvial la deuxième vie du
canal du midi maradan nous construit au
xviie siècle le canal du midi relie
toulouse à la méditerranée sa vocation
c'est le transport du fret
un inventaire riche d'un autre temps
trois cent cinquante mille tonnes de
céréales
cent mille tonnes d'hydrocarbures
cinquante mille tonnes de 20 75 mille
tonnes de matériaux de construction
quarante mille tonnes de phosphate et de
pâte à papier 142 péniche naviguer sur
le canal cette année là mais la
concurrence du rail de la route a tué la
batellerie au milieu des années 70 ça
sent la fin
la dernière on est resté pratiquement
sept mois à bricoler la table du tout
les péniches sont à vendre
ce mariniers venait de se débarrasser de
la sienne elle servira pour la plaisance
maintenant les anglais voilà le nouvel
usage de ces bateaux de labeur promène
touristes une activité qui prospérait
déjà dans les années 70 ces hollandais
ces anglais ces allemands ces américains
que viennent ils chercher ici le soleil
du midi le ciel bleu et au bout du
voyage la lumière étincelante de la
méditerranée elle fronçait aussi se
convertiront et en 1996 le canal du midi
est inscrit au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco
c'est le jackpot le tourisme fluvial
explose cette semaine on sort des
américains des australiens des gens
d'une nouvelle zélande des anglais les
allemands bien monsieur des français
bien sûr
malgré de timides tentatives le
transport de fret n'est pas revenu sur
le canal 18
l'ouvragé de 240km vide ces touristes et
de ces plaisanciers mais ils partagent
comme notre mariniers de 1968 ce même
sentiment ont pu noter un gros jouet son
sensation de liberté
[Musique]